why is it not acceptable to be
introverted or bookish or a little bit
nerdy or whatever what is every single
woman it has to be about this hotness
and and not just when they're young but
as they go to their 30s their 40s their
50s you know it it just seems like yet
what happened to growing old gracefully
and just accepting the the point in your
life that you are at they don't want to
lose control they don't want to lose
control I think that women get to a
point where you know they're the hottest
they've ever been maybe 1920 and every
guy is talking to them they can't walk
down the street without a guy coming and
say hello to them and then once you get
over to 35 you stop getting those
compliments